let's go next to preston from maryland
preston welcome to the program
hello can you hear me i can preston you
you have not called in before have you
uh i actually did call in once a while
ago during a trump rally oh okay but my
brain was so turned to mush but i
couldn't even
think of a question your brain was
mayonnaise from the rally and you had to
hang up on it
all right good
yeah
so um so what what can we do
as the american people to kind of
counter
the left right red team versus blue team
sort of tribalism that just keeps
getting worse and worse every year it
seems oh well see the problem with that
question is i
you know there's there's a couple how do
i even want to approach this
i think that the degree of tribalism
that we have in the united states is a
problem there are people who will just
support or oppose
ideas
based on the letter next to someone's
name whether it's an r or a d i think
that a lot of these things are bad the
concern is
a lot of the people talking about
tribalism these days
want to sort of portray themselves as
the enlightened centrists who are above
partisan politics and fairly evaluate
every issue and all these different
things and want to find some kind of
middle ground when there really is no
reasonable middle ground on so many
issues there's no middle ground between
climate change is real based on the
science and climate change is imaginary
well so it's kind of real well that
that's crazy and so my concern is i'm
not saying this about you necessarily
preston but sometimes when people when
they they just say tribalism's really
the issue
there's a little bit of this both sides
enlightened centrism stuff going on
where some of these people are nuts
there's no working with them they just
we need to figure out a way to get them
out of politics
yeah i can understand that
all right
yeah can you can you hear me i can hear
you fine preston
no
oh yeah yes so
oh yeah that's that's a pretty
good point i don't really have any
follow-up
i'm sorry
all right very good preston we're losing
you so i'm going to let you go preston
very interesting topic and we've talked
a lot about this enlightened centrism
thing and it's quite a quite a situation